- Welcome everyone,
I'm Jacqueline Goldsby,
I'm Chair of the African
American Studies Department.
And it's really, really wonderful
to be able to welcome you
to the first in a series
of Endeavors Colloquiums
for this semester.
I won't let it go without
saying that I wish
we could be gathering
together in physical,
real time space with each other
at the department's building
on campus 81 Wall Street in
the Gordon Park Seminar room
where we traditionally hold
these thought, gatherings,
these think tanks,
but we are where we are with the pandemic
and the ways in which Zoom
actually makes different
kinds of convenings possible,
that actually have led to
having some exciting thought
leaders here with us today,
so we will run with the virtual space
but I don't wanna let it go without saying
that we would traditionally
be holding this
in our department building,
but we are in the Zoom space.
And I just want to point
out a few logistical points
for all of us to get today.
You should have received the
message that we are recording
this session and we will
be posting it online
so that it's available to anyone
to think with the ideas that
are gonna be raised here today.
But for that reason,
we would ask that you mute your mics
so that we can have a
kind of clean soundtrack
for the recording.
And also when we turn to Q and A,
but as the discussion evolves and moves,
feel free to post your
questions, your comments,
your thoughts in the chat
and our facilitator for today
will be tracking that space
and bring your ideas and bring your voices
into the discussion when we
hit that part of the program.
I just wanna flag for us
that this is the first
in the series of colloquium
that we'll be having this spring,
and remind us all
and especially for those of
you who are new and our guests,
that there are a couple of unique features
about the Endeavor series
that's worth naming
since we're coming back together
after not holding the
series last semester.
One thing about our department colloquium
is that it's department wide.
In other departments tend
to organize by sub-fields,
but we bring everyone together
because in African-American Studies,
we approach questions and
issues and plan making
we want to pursue
interdisciplinarily, right,
bringing the disciplines together.
And so we bring everyone
in this shared space.
And another feature about our colloquium
is that it's a space for
incubating and fostering new ideas,
new art, new scholarship,
new ways to be engaged in community work.
And so we're really excited
to be thinking at the edge
of what's happening in our
respective disciplines,
but together to move the new ideas,
to push the endeavors out,
hints the title of our series.
I wanna point out that this
semester we're focusing
on breakthrough ideas,
breakthrough models,
breakthrough provocations,
they are coming to us
from the social sciences.
And so we'll be convening sociologists,
political scientists,
psychologists, economists,
anthropologists, to
really push our thinking
about the leading issues
that are shaping Black life worlds today.
And so I just wanna mark
some future dates for you.
On March 31st, my
colleague Professor Amy Cox
will facilitate a panel discussion
on the anthropology of abolition,
which will bring together
are really exciting
anthropologists who are setting
the carceral state and state violence.
And then we're looking and
finalizing panels for April
where we'll focus on
race in higher education.
And the case for reparations,
which is, you know,
at Yale is a very live discussion
given the work of the Yale
and slavery working group.
So those panels will
be happening in April,
and as soon as we confirm the speakers
we'll let you know,
but do mark March 31st,
where we'll have Savannah saying change,
Christian Smith and Deborah Thomas with us
to talk about the
anthropology of abolition.
Today's panel on Black activism
amidst community violence
will be facilitated by my
colleague, Professor Philip Goff.
And I'll hand it over to Professor Goff
to introduce our panelists today.
- Thank you so much, Jackie,
for those introductory remarks
and for all of your
leadership of this department
that allows us to have
these kinds of conversation,
wanted to make sure that my
mute off button has worked.
So can I get a thumbs up
that from the panelists
that folks are hearing
me, thank you so much.
It's a rare pleasure
in doing academic work
that you get to hear from national leaders
together in conversation.
That's part of what we're
trying to do this semester
to in certain part compensate for Zoom,
and to create a little bit
more sense of community.
So it's a rare pleasure
that we get to do that.
It is also a rare pleasure
to be able to do that
while talking to people
I've considered friends
for a number of years.
So I'm mostly going to
want to get out of the way,
I'm gonna do a little bit of housekeeping
and do a little bit of
sort of shaping of it.
But I mostly want you all to get a chance
to experience the genius
we have been so fortunate
to collect for today.
The little bit of housekeeping as Jackie
had mentioned previously,
if you can please mute your
video and your mic throughout
because we are doing a recording.
If you've got questions, please, please,
please, put it in the chat.
And I will go ahead and
facilitate that when it comes time
to the Q and A, and for
ease of your own viewing,
if you would like we
encourage you to go ahead
and put the presentation on speaker view,
just as we move through.
With that, let me go ahead
and frame this conversation
that I couldn't be more excited
to just be listening to,
I know I gotta facilitate it too,
which is this, the past two
years have seen the largest
single set of protests in
human history by all accounts.
They were around racial injustice,
public safety and policing
systems in the United States,
but they went global.
Those protests and the
organizing and activism
that surrounded them that
was in response to them
has not stopped.
And yet at the same time, the levers,
the pendulum of sort of
racial momentum have shifted
in those two years from one
of our international appetite
for significant change,
not just in criminal legal systems,
but of course all the systems
and that feed into them
to one where just today,
we're hearing stories
that all of those protests
in fact were a fools errand
that they have gone far too far
and that they have asked
for and even pushed,
achieved too much.
The reality of course,
is that while protests were massive
and demands were radically
sort of oriented,
the amount that has
changed is much smaller.
And that is in the national narrative.
And all of that is within the context
of a controversially
affiliated spike, not in crime,
but in murder, in violence
within communities.
And in fact, it is that spike in violence
within communities that has
led many folks to say, well,
these new demands, these new
policies must be at fault.
We must go back to way the
things were, this is overreach.
First, let me say that
we have to acknowledge
the murder spike is real.
It is not some form of propaganda.
It is not faked data.
I specialize in identifying fake data,
particularly in public safety
and the most reliable data
that you can get ever from law enforcement
are those that can be double
checked at the morgue.
Black communities have been and hurting
in the midst of the last two years,
not just from the pandemic,
not just from the economic
consequences thereof,
but from community violence.
And yet there is written nowhere,
a law that says it is in fact
when violence is at its
heightened communities,
that we must rely on punitive institutions
to remedy it, right?
The argument can easily
be made if police budgets
where at their height in the
midst of this while on earth,
where we need to increase policing, right?
There is significant question
about where and when and how
policing as opposed to
community empowerment
drives down that violence,
prevents that violence,
even predicts it?
These questions are in the
context of the long struggle
for Black liberation,
the tension between what
do we need to do right now,
amidst the hell that
Black folks are catching
and what do we need to
plan for in the future,
so that there is a future where
we're not demanding justice,
but we are experiencing freedom?
How do we move within that?
What are the appropriate
roles for academia?
And what do we see as the trends,
the promises within activism organizing
and a collective united voice
to demand changes of the experiences
that we're having right now?
I could think of no better group of humans
to talk to us about that,
than the four assembled for us
who will then go on to solve
all of these problems,
no pressure, low bar.
We're gonna be hearing
from in order Nikki Jones,
who is Professor and H. Michael
and Jean Williams Department
Chair of African-American Studies
at the African-American Studies
Department at UC Berkeley.
She is one of the, if not per
generations, my generations,
greatest ethnographers of the
forms of invisible violence
we have done to Black people,
generally Black women
and girls in particular
that is invisible that she makes visible.
She's awarded the American
Society of Criminology,
outstanding research award in 2020.
Her list goes on and on.
I encourage you to read
"Between Good and Ghetto,"
her first book, as well as
her many, many articles,
the regular routine, all of them.
These are staples in my classes
and have radically shaped the way
in which I think about these issues.
She will speak first.
Second will be Patrick Sharkey,
who is the William S. Todd
Professor of Sociology
and Public Affairs at
Princeton University.
Perhaps no one has written
as careful and nuanced
a take on what is happening
in particularly urban pockets
of violence than Pat Sharkey.
I can and will go on and on,
but he is perhaps most notably for this
if folks are looking for the website,
the Founder of americanviolence.org,
go there, it is an amazing resource,
and I cannot tell you how excited I am
that he is here to speak with us.
Third, Brandon Terry,
who is a Presidential visiting
Assistant Professor here
at Yale this series.
And he is an Assistant Professor
of African-American Studies
and American Studies and of
Social Studies at Harvard,
'cause he likes to have
multiple affiliations.
He is a preeminent thinker and scholar
of Black radical political fault.
And I'm excited to hear
how he's going to be framing this moment
in terms of how Black leadership
can and should be a
continuation and a departure
of the legacies that we bring with us.
And last but certainly not
least Pastor Michael McBride
is a native side of San Francisco,
he got a ministry in
Oakland for over 20 years.
Pastor McBride is the Executive
Director of Live Free USA,
a nonprofit committed
to ending gun violence.
He is an intellectual
leader, a movement leader,
a moral leader on these
issues and well beyond.
So mostly what I wanna do,
as I said is get the heck out of the way
to let these folk rip on
giving us some more wisdom
with regards to these issues
where the pendulum has
not only swung back,
but it has sharp edges and
it is pushing us further away
from where we're trying
to go than we were before
the public lynching of
George Floyd May 25th, 2020.
Dr. Nikki Jones, could you
please offer some initial remarks
before we get to the Q and A?
- Sure, sure.
- And I'll proceed to each of them,
each folks after that.
- Yeah, and thank you, Professor
Goff for that introduction,
for the invitation to be here.
Thank you, Vanessa,
for all the work that
you did behind the scenes
to get us in this virtual space together.
And thank you Professor Goldsby
for those introductory comments
and the invitation to think together.
I'm joining you here from
Berkeley unseated alone
in the territory in the Bay Area.
I'm joining you at a moment
that is really a reflective moment for me
and thinking about what we've learned
from the uprisings of summer 2020,
especially context of policing and working
in the area of policing
over the course of my career
and seeing for the first
time in our history
where we are seeing the pairing,
the intertwining of uprisings
against systemic racism
and police violence,
which is much different
even from seven years ago,
the call for police reforms.
And so that has been
very clarifying for me.
So thinking deeply about
what Black activists
have always encouraged us us to do
is to see things more clearly
to sharpen our vision,
to better understand
and define the problem.
And so what are the things
that I know with more certainty
because of the work that I've done
over the course of my career
and because of this particular moment.
Now first we know,
and I think more people understand
that policing is not one thing.
And so we often talk about
policing a bit large,
but I think if we just think
about the media coverage
of the "Black Lives Matter" protest
of the uprisings of summer 2020,
and the violence that
was freely distributed
upon protestors,
and then we think about the
insurrection on January 6th,
and people trying to make
sense of what they're seeing
and the reserve in which violence was held
when the mob, right,
when the, the uprising,
the insurrection was led by White people
and to large degree White nationalist.
And so more folks understood
that policing is not the same,
always, but certainly in
the work that I've done.
I have understood that
both in the epigraphic work
and certainly came to appreciate that more
in the work that I've done interviewing
and studying police officers
who very freely share that
policing is not one thing,
they don't police neighborhoods the same
in that the brunt of that
violence and aggression
often comes down on the
bodies of Black youth
like those I've spent time with
over the course of my career.
I think this moment is also
called on us to think critically
about policing as a response to violence
in a way that that is much more refined,
I think, than we have previously.
And to better appreciate
an argument that I make
in my most recent book,
"The Chosen Ones" that policing
acts as a co-constructor
of violence and that's not hyperbole,
and it's not even a radical position
to say that policing is about violence.
Policing scholars have
said this for 50+ years
that violence is central to policing.
And in the course of my
work as Phil alluded to,
I certainly, I am thinking
about the extraordinary forms
of violence and the spectacles of violence
that we've come to to see,
and that motivate people.
But I've spent a lot of time
to thinking about the ordinary violence,
the routine violence in
the way that the body
becomes an archive for that violence.
The body becomes conditioned.
The bodies of young
people become conditioned
to that violence.
And I think we have other
archives of that as well.
We can think about pattern
and practice investigations,
for example, and people
often, you know, wanna know,
is this a kind of reform
that can change policing?
And I take a slightly
different look at these records
and think about the ways
in which it's an archive
of the routine violence,
of the ordinary violence that
is common until it's not,
until it's made extraordinary by an act.
But then if you look back,
you see that the record of
routine violence was there.
And if that's the case, then, you know,
I think we have to think
critically about not the role
of policing and responding
to this murder spike,
this spike in violence,
but what is the role of state violence
in responding to violence?
And what are the limits of that?
And so certainly thinking
about the kind of not expanding
the narrow way in which we
often thought about policing
as a response or as a
provider of public safety.
And then I think this moment,
well I hope we have learned
and what I know folks are
pushing us to appreciate
is the way that this moment is an echo.
It's an echo of earlier times
going back centuries, right?
But it is an echo in this
moment of very recent history
of the 80s and 90s, right.
Where we have these racialized
fears around empirical facts.
So just like Professor Goff
said, yes, there is this spike.
How do we respond to that?
And what is the role of racialized fear?
So certainly the kind
of the racialized images
of Black criminality
are coming to the fore,
whether they're explicitly
addressed or not.
And it makes it difficult for us
to really appreciate the
depth of the problem.
And so certainly we
think about gun violence
as concentrated in cities
and among Black youth
and Latinx youth.
And yet we know that there's been increase
in domestic violence as well, right?
And that that's gun violence,
but that's not the vision
that we are bringing
when we have this kind
of really narrow way
of thinking about the problem,
and it's intentionally narrow, right.
Because it's not actually
about addressing the problem,
it's about politicizing the problem
and certainly political power.
So those are a few things
that are more clarified for me
moving through this moment.
And then I appreciate,
and I just wanna, so I'll
close, I'll stop there for now,
but just to say that, you know,
I'm really looking forward
to being in this conversation
and learning from the
other panelists, thank you.
- Thank you so much, Dr. Jones.
Dr. Sharkey, could you speak
to the people a little bit?
- Yeah, I'd love to.
Thanks for having me with this group.
Man, I've learned so
much from Dr. Jones work.
It's great to be on the same panel
and to be at Yale where I
think some of the best work,
probably the best work on around
these issues is happening.
So I started studying violence
because the more evidence
I looked at, the more I
began to think of violence
as central to understanding
inequality in the U.S
and that's reciprocal.
So urban inequality creates
the conditions for violence
to emerge by concentrating
disadvantage in the U.S,
by bringing about sustained disinvestment
in core community institutions,
by leading to a system of punishment.
And that's U.S specific as well.
But through these mechanisms,
urban inequality creates the conditions
for violent to emerge,
but then violence amplifies
and reinforces inequality.
And it does that directly
by taking young lives,
but it also does that by
impeding academic performance
and achievement by influencing
the economic outcomes
of young people, by
enhancing mental illness,
by undermining communities.
So that's the frame at which
I started to see violence
as fundamental to understanding
inequality in the U.S.
And then the question is, well,
when we look at what has
happened since the 1990s,
so violence fell by roughly
half from early 1990s to 2014.
So what happened?
What brought about that change?
And that's why I started
studying community organizations,
the movements that were
happening in neighborhoods
across the country.
So I think it was 2015,
I sat down with three graduate students,
basically because we were
unsatisfied with the explanations
for why violence fell, read
all these inspiring books
about organizations and
people who had mobilized
to retake public spaces and make them safe
for communities to march
against violence to mobilize,
to provide services for mental illness,
for addiction to provide basic services
like after school programs
and communities that were hit hardest
by the rise of violence
in the 70s and 80s.
And so when we looked at national data,
we were basically trying
to figure out, okay,
we have these explanations
for why violence fell,
what else was happening on the ground?
And we looked, we gathered all the data
that we could in cities
across the country.
And we found the stuff that
other people had found.
So there was a large scale
increase in police force,
there were changes in police tactics.
There was a continued
rise in incarceration.
There was an expansion of surveillance
and closed circuit camera
systems implemented
in cities across the country.
But there was also
something else that we saw.
There was a mobilization
of the nonprofit sector
that occurred at a national level.
So these stories are told
in terms of heroic acts
of individuals or were
specific groups of people
in a given neighborhood,
and they should be told that way,
they are heroic acts.
This is my comments are
not meant to diminish
the incredible work that's going on
in neighborhoods across country.
But what I would point out
is that this was a national mobilization
that took place in the early 1990s,
the nonprofit sector,
particularly organizations
that were formed
to deal with violence,
but also just to build
stronger communities,
you can see in the national data,
there's proliferation.
So what we did in that first study,
where I looked at the impact
of this mobilization of
nonprofit organizations,
was to try to identify causal evidence,
to see whether there was a causal impact
of the expansion of the nonprofit
sector on violent crime.
And in that first study that we did,
Delaram Takyar was one
of the graduate students,
Gerard Torrats-Espinoza was
another and Kiera Darts.
I wanna make sure to give them all credit.
What we found is that,
so we exploited kind of shocks in funding
that led to more nonprofits emerging
to identify the causal impact.
What we found is that in a typical city,
a city with about 100,000 people,
every 10 additional
nonprofits that were formed
to deal with violence,
to retake public spaces,
to provide services, to provide housing,
to provide after school programs,
led to about a 9% drop in the murder rate.
The implication of this
is that in addition
to all those other changes
that get so much attention
about shifts in policing and
incarceration and so forth,
there was a mobilization that took place
in the communities hit
hardest by violence.
That mobilization expansion of nonprofits
played a central role in contributing
to the fall of violence from
the 1990s to the mid 2010s.
The reason that's important
is because when you think
about the explanations
for why violence fell,
or when you think about the reactions
to the recent rise in violence
in the U.S, we immediately go back
to this knee jerk reaction
and think about a response
that is focused on the
institutions of punishment,
the police and the prison system,
that is the default response
to arise of violence in the U.S.
This evidence provides a proof of concept
that a different approach is necessary.
The groups that mobilized in the 1990s
are groups that were underfunded,
that did not have national support
that were not seen as central actors
in the effort to deal with violence,
and yet they had this enormous impact
on the decline in violence.
They played a central role in that effort.
So this observation is reinforced
by a whole bunch of
randomized control trials.
The evidence base has grown
stronger and stronger,
and what it tells us is
that we have had a model
for a long time that assumes
that to deal with rising
violence we have to turn back
to the institutions of
punishment in the U.S.
There is another model,
the groups and the people
that have always had the greatest capacity
to control violence or
organizations that are motivated
by building stronger neighborhoods,
by looking out for their neighbors,
making sure everybody's
welcome in their community,
making sure their communities stay strong
and no one falls through the cracks.
Those organizations,
we now know we have enough evidence now
to know that those organizations
have the greatest capacity
to control violence,
and yet they've just never
been given the commitment
and the resources to do
so in a sustained way.
So I think, you know,
the main message here is
that we can make a case
for the work that Pastor Mike is doing
the work that's going
on around the country,
on the merits of justice,
we can praise the work that's going on,
the incredible hard work that's going on
without sufficient resources,
but we can also make an empirical case.
This work is not only how I
think the world should work,
it is backed up by extraordinary
evidence at this point.
- Thank you, Dr. Sharkey.
Dr. Terry, you wanna speak to the people?
- So first off,
I want to thank Phil for convening us here
for inviting me really
honored to be in conversation
with you all who have learned so much
from and been inspired by.
I'm a political theorist.
So I come at these questions
from a bit of a different vantage,
and I wanted to open up
by speaking forthrightly
of what I think is a
kind of ghost haunting,
these kinds of discussions
about community violence.
And that's the older idea
or concept of Black on Black crime.
Community violence is arrayed productively
against this earlier once prominent idea.
And it's an attempt to replace race based
with police based arguments.
But for someone like me who
was formed in many respects
by the 1990s period,
that Pat is talking a about,
the decline of Black on Black crime talk
is really fascinating.
So it was once a familiar
part of Black liberal,
nationalist and radical discourse.
But now it's principally
used by conservative critics
of "Black Lives Matter,"
writers like Ta-Nehisi Coates,
decry its use as ideological and cynical.
They say it represents an
illicit changing of the subject
against legitimate demands
of anti-racist activists.
And sociologically, I think the consensus
is that Black on Black violence concepts,
lead analysts to confuse the
effects of racial segregation
for a unique pathology of Black people,
think it unfairly racializes crime,
further stigmatizes Blacks,
and perhaps even more devastating
is that the concept seems to suggest
the need for an explanation
of why to quote Alvin Poussaint's
book title from the 1970s,
"Blacks Kill Blacks."
And this peculiar demand
for an explanation
tends to generate odd Black
psychology in Poussaint form,
it drew on the "Wretched of the Earth"
and he wrote things like "By
attacking a fellow Black,
"we may feel that we are
committing a manly act,
"the destruction of sin itself.
"We may express our self rejection
"by acting out the White racist wish."
So this idea of internalized oppression,
despite its origins and
Black power radicalism
licensed surprising
support for authoritarian
and violent repression of
Black crime and Black people
as Black radicals themselves
became more despairing
of the prospects for the revolution
and consciousness that might
shed these opposed pathologies
through politics.
Now, given the flaws of
the picture I just painted,
it's easy to narrate the turn
to the community violence
concept as progressive
and an instance of genuine
sociological learning.
But I think if we're too
triumphant about that story,
I think we miss something
about the popularity
of Black on Black crime discourse
in Black communities that might help us
to produce a still more effective theory,
politics and rhetoric in the present.
So I think there's a
slight of hand in the way
that some analysts conflate
the White dominated discourse
about Black crime from the 1890s
and its obsessions with
Black on White crime,
especially rape with the
discourse on Black on Black crime
a century later,
the latter was not driven by White racist
and Black reactionaries alone,
but was embraced by all
manner of anti-racist artist,
intellectuals activist from Jesse Jackson
to Sister Souljah to Tupac Shakur.
And what we tend to miss I
think is that Black on Black
crime talk can essentially be
split into two overlapping,
but analytically distinct
families of thought.
The first which we've discussed
already is sociological
and explanatory in its aspiration.
The other however is normative.
It's about ethics and politics.
So in its normative construction,
Black on Black crime reflects views
about social critique and moral duties.
The argument was that
Black on Black violence
was not just a problem,
but a matter of justice,
it reflects unremedy effects
of broader systemic injustice
and social abandonment.
It intensifies unfair racial stigma
and violates basic rights
of Blacks themselves.
Further the failure,
the state to effectively
enforce the rule of law
or exhibit meaningful concern
when Blacks harm other Blacks
reflects a cultivated
disregard for Black dignity
and citizenship.
And as my friend, Tommy Shelby
argues in "Dark Ghettos,"
such conditions call into
question the very legitimacy
of the whole legal and political order,
as well as the demand
that the oppressed comply
with the law or that they
respect property rights
or contribute to norms of cooperation.
The problem with this critique, however,
is that it opens up a
dangerous and frightening moral
and political void.
How can we sustain respect for rights?
How can we sustain cooperative
struggles against injustice?
How can we sustain collective
survival and flourishing
without the appeal to legitimate law?
On my view,
what Black on Black crime talk tried to do
was use racial solidarity
to fill that void.
In other words,
it offers an argument to
those considering violence
or criminal practices,
which presupposed violence,
and it suggests that such
violence is not just a violation
of peoples natural rights,
but violate special solideistic norms,
like special concern, loyalty,
the promotion of shared goals and trust.
These goals, the framework
suggest are necessary
for the struggle against anti-Black racism
and the cultivation of
a bearable social life
amidst injustice.
Black on Black violence on their view
then is a violation of obligations
born of shared oppression
instead of strengthening solidarity,
it deepens and hardens
patterns of distrust,
makes it harder to
sustain across class ties
and create psychological
and social traumas
that make the work of
movement building harder.
It also events as a
kind of cruel parasitism
amidst shared vulnerability.
Now in closing, and to reiterate,
I'm not offering a
defense of the discourse,
but I'm just pointing out
how different it looks
from this normative angle,
as opposed to the explanatory one.
Despite its faults Black
on Black crime talk
properly reconstructed
seems to take seriously
a broad suite of challenges
that I think any replacement discourse
concerned with Black activism
amidst community violence
also needs to consider.
I'll close by restating
them quickly as follows.
The first is a critique of the legitimacy
of the existing social and legal order
and a related recognition that
certain forms of law breaking
are forms of legitimate dissent.
Second is a recognition
that this critique discloses
a crisis of normativity
that severely dangerous
to social life and demands a
kind of normative refounding.
Third is a question of
how to be respectful
of and responsive to the
moral and political agency
of the perpetrators and
victims of violence.
And last is responding to
existing normative expectations
of Black solidarity
and anti-race struggle,
anti-race struggle.
So I think this helps us see more clearly
what was normatively self
undermining about the answers
Black on Black crime
discourse tended to generate
to the incisive ethical and
political questions it posed,
it's premona failed to
adequately distinguish
their normative and explanatory ambitions,
and they left the concept vulnerable
to use our patient by
authoritarian reactionaries.
The fixation on the spectacular
character of violence
moreover often degenerated
into what we see as one sided
demands for solidaristic discipline
expressed by Black elites
against the ghetto poor,
without equal attention to
the failure of mutual concern
in the other direction.
And finally, in most perniciously,
it reflect the roots in Black nationalism
by permitting the conceptual
partitioning of political space
and moral responsibility such
that Black on Black crime
became only a challenge for the
supposed autonomous politics
of Black communities rather
than generating duties
of response for the whole society.
To the extent that any
community violence paradigm
failed to pose these
important normative questions
or reflexively reproduces these flaws,
I think will undermine some
of the important potential
gained in moving from
Black on Black crime talk
to community violence talk
that we supposedly are experiencing.
I'll stop there.
- Thank you so much, Dr. Terry,
and in by way of transition,
I love to move from the ghosts
of racism to the Holy Ghost.
So Pastor Mike, you wanna go
ahead and bless the people.
- Touch your baby with consent.
When you introduce me
talking about the Holy Ghost.
I'm gonna get excited now.
It's great to be here with everyone.
Obviously, you know,
so much has been said.
I agree with all of it.
I will like to introduce my perspective
or remarks just around this idea
of my greatest concern.
This moment presents to me,
it is around narrative and it
is around how we make meaning
of the worst conditions in
Black and Brown communities
in a manner that does not
recycle the very things
that so many reasonable
people the last several years
had an epiphany around.
It is a question to me,
not just a proximity,
but of empathy.
It is a question of, do we
believe that Black communities
belong to the United States of America?
Or are we a burden?
And we just want Black folks
and others to die silently
and invisibly without the
responsibility of the whole nation
to fix what the nation broke, right?
And I do believe we are in a
crisis moment because you know,
I'm 46 years old.
I lived through 90s as a teenager,
and I got caught up in being
a victim of police brutality.
I have friends who have
been beat up by cops.
I have friends who've been
shot and killed by guns.
And so while some may have
the luxury to uncouple
the issue of policing and quote unquote
"intra communal violence,"
the overwhelming majority of Black folks
caught in these cycles both are directly
or through proximity
with their family members
are waking up every
day, trying to navigate
the existential presence
of violence in their lives
that could come upon them
unexpected with no protection
and with no security.
It is really important I
think for us to appreciate
that it is a false distinction
between a victim and a perpetrator.
It is about where you come
into the story of that person,
will we treat them as the
victimized or the victimizer?
Violence creates all kinds of
trauma that without therapy
and support and healing remains
in the soul, the spirit,
the body, and the mind of the
person who's been victimized.
And so when we talk about
violence in our communities,
and we try to divide, even
within our own communities,
folks into good versus bad, you know,
victim versus perpetrator,
it really muddies the water in a way
that I believe caused us to lose out
on the opportunity to talk
about communal killing,
communal stabilization and
what must be done to stabilize
Black communities that
have not spent one day
in this country and not
experienced state violence
at the hand of largely
White led institutions.
Now I want you to think about that, right?
Not one day in this country,
have we not experienced the violence
of White man institutions,
both governmental corporate or otherwise,
and yet our angst and our retribution
is pointed towards the very folks
who are being victimized regularly.
It is as if we are asking Black folks
who are experiencing
these levels of trauma
to rise above the trauma
and assure the violence
that has been thrust upon
us without any resources
to be healed, to be restored
or to be stabilized.
And so I do believe that
we have a crisis moment
around narrative.
I do think that we all want
to be safe in our communities,
but the tough on crime
approach has proven to us
to not be the answer.
There's a scripture that says, you know,
if you hear the word,
but don't do the word,
you are like a person who
looks at their reflection
in the mirror and walks away
and forget what you saw.
Well, I wanna say that we can't last year,
I'll talk about we need to
limit the footprint of policing,
radically reimagined public safety,
and then allow the conservative forces
largely led by police unions
who are in their own self description
supported of the authoritarian
impulses of Donald Trump
and those forces,
we want to unleash these individuals
into our communities to create safety
while they are all the wild resisting,
any form of reform and accountability.
These are the folks we wanna
give have more money to.
I heard President Biden at
the police foundation say,
"We don't wanna defund the police
"we wanna give you more money."
Why? So you can do therapy, healing.
We want to ask police
officers to provide therapy
to Pookie or Ray-Ray
that's the most brilliant
community safety strategy that
the leader of this country
is proud to publicly proclaim.
And then you want folks who
actively work on this every day
to rob Peter to pay Paul
to sell chicken dinners,
to sell t-shirts, to fund
a public safety strategy
that has been 400 years
in the making of a crisis.
I do believe people that
we must be as serious
about this problem as we are
about killing Black people
in this country.
This is a huge challenge
for our communities
in the midst of a global pandemic
that has ravaged the infrastructure,
the familial ties and
stability of Black communities
and poor communities and many communities.
And so I do believe the
conversation that we have today
is a conversation about politics
and conversation about, you
know, the kind of frameworks
we use to describe and
to define the phenomena
that is happening in our communities.
But it is also about how do
we love Black folks, right?
How do we love folks into life?
And I do know now,
and I'll say a little bit
more of this later on,
but I do know that there are folks
within the Black community who live
in very violent communities
and it is they themselves
often calling for more police.
But I think it's important for us to know
that we have found strategies
that when people learn
about these strategies
they actually will ask
for these strategies as well.
So the question for us is how
do we mainstream and socialize
our broader public and
conversation around things
that not only we know work,
but that we know community members
who live in these communities
will actually embrace
and remove the kind of political anxiety
of elected officials who claim
to want to end mass incarceration.
They claim they want
to end criminalization.
They claim they want to
end police shootings,
but don't wanna do anything systemically
to assist in that process.
And so I am very grateful to be included
in this conversation.
I can go on and on, but I'll stop there
because I would love to
continue to, you know,
have the Holy Ghost be activated in me
by these great scholars
from these prestigious
wonderful institutions.
- Did you really end with
Holy Spirit activate?
Is that what happened, Pastor Mike?
(Philip laughs)
- Hey man, no, if it
ain't got that spirit,
it ain't got that swag, you understand me?
Come on.
- Oh, I could not appreciate
the four of y'all more
what a tremendous set of opening remarks,
what I'm trying to distill themes.
And before I get there,
everyone who is here,
part of the audience,
we do want you to be able to participate.
If you've got questions,
please do put them in the chat,
and I will relay them here
as part of our ongoing conversation.
But as I'm pulling out themes
from where Nikki started
and Pastor Mike where you end,
one of the themes that
seems like it's very clear
is that the stories that
we're telling are lies, right?
The narratives that we've got
insufficient for this moment,
and there are two examples
that kind of came out to me,
particularly Brandon, as you were talking,
one was the tragic story
of Ma'Khia Bryant, right?
If you recall immediately after
the trial of Derek Chauvin,
she's a young African American
girl who was shot and killed.
She was in foster care.
She had a knife,
it looked in the body cam video
like she was lunging at another girl.
And initially, because
it was a Black girl,
it was a child who was
killed by law enforcement,
there was great alarm and the
body cam footage came out.
People said, "Well, she had a knife.
"It looked like she was lunging.
"What else could the officer have done?
"It was a good shooting.
"It was a fine shooting.
"How can you possibly object?"
And I thought about that
between Brandon and Pastor Mike,
because the conversation
we had at my center,
woman named Tracy Lloyd
with tears in her eyes said,
"We wouldn't have that conversation
as the only two options
"like she was wronged, or she deserved it.
"If the people who were in
charge of keeping us safe,
"loved her."
We would be able to imagine a world
where a child who was moved
between multiple foster homes,
which we know a right for
various kinds of abuse
and neglect, right?
If that child's life was not
about what they chose to do
in that moment, but the options
that were afforded to her.
And perhaps interestingly,
it paired in my mind with
the conversation I was having
last night about the
tragic, tragic killing
of a young woman,
Christina Lee in Chinatown in New York.
And it looks as if the
individual who stabbed her
was a terrible murder stabbed her 40 times
in her own apartment.
It's a stranger issue,
which is incredibly rare
as we know from the literature,
just to the caricature of
the worst kinds of murder,
but the individual who
stabbed her was 25 years old.
Last address was a homeless shelter.
And it was in a neighborhood
where the community had
got banned together to say,
we don't want more homeless shelters
'cause we're scared of homeless people.
And it says if because
the spectacle of violence
is so extraordinary of
that physical violence,
it's so extraordinary that
it blinds us to the violence
of poverty and neglect that
causes it in the first place.
And so with the concerns around narrative,
these concerns about what is missing,
the levels that which we're
not having conversation.
I have a question for the panel
and I'm happy for y'all
to go in whatever order
and to speak to each other,
which is what obligation
is there among Black folks
or folks who are championing
the Black radical imagination
within this space to
the White assumptions,
the White gaze upon this space?
What things do Black folks owe
to what White people imagine
around what's happening
in Black communities?
'Cause it does seem as
if part of the narratives
that are made invisible
are the narratives that
are hardest to explain
to a White imagination of Blackness.
So if that question makes sense,
I would love for any of
the panelists to go ahead
and get started.
And if nobody wants to,
I absolutely will call on y'all.
- I can start, my first response
is we owe nothing to the White imagination
because the White imagination
is not constructed
And the way that we're talking about
in the central bowl of
violence in that way,
it's not constructed to
serve Black communities.
And I think, you know,
each person laid that out,
particularly, you know, Pastor Mike,
this idea that the solution lies in there
I think has been challenged
again and again and again.
And I do see that as a
problem of the narrative.
And so thinking about this,
I wrote an article recently,
"I Am A Child," right?
A girl child's truth and the
lie eyes of law enforcement.
And it's about the girl child.
And I'm using here the words
of June Jordan in Rochester,
New York, who was pepper
sprayed by officers.
And in that piece,
I do a step by step
analysis of the encounter
and the moment in which the
girl child tells the truth
to law enforcement,
"I Am A Child" calling them
on their failure to recognize
to see them, but we understand,
and your work is well,
Professor Goff, right?
That these institutions
have been conditioned
to misread us, right?
To not see us, right.
And so you can imagine
that the work will go
into either helping people
see or keeping us alive.
And the work of keeping us alive is deep
in the Black radical tradition, right?
And in our daily practices.
And if we think for
example about abolition
and how that's emerged
as a possibility in a way
in this moment that it
hasn't very long time.
Part of that is recognizing
the day to day practices,
not only abolition as a political project,
but as a political project
that's embedded in daily practices.
That act of love that Pastor
Mike is talking about,
I know a young person
is leading down a path
and in my neighborhood,
how do I approach them?
Understanding the challenges with that,
which is something,
you know, I've read about
in the "Chosen Ones,"
building that world.
And one of the things that
I've learned from folks
who are doing this work
over the last couple years,
as we imagine the top down.
At the top, people have moved
through this racial reckoning
really the people on the ground
are still doing the work.
Why are they doing the work?
Because they're doing the care work
that what it means to be a community,
it's what it means to care for each other
and people so people are doing that work
and people are gonna
continue to do that work.
I do think that thinking
about investing in that work
is really important.
The narrative for investment,
I think, you know,
Pat's work is compelling
for folks because of that.
And at the same time,
it has to be a narrative
that is centered in the value
of Black life and Black humanity.
And those two, right, can often collide.
- And can I just add and say,
it must be centered in Black
life and Black humanity,
but also Black leadership
or leadership of those
who demonstrate love,
public love for Black people.
And so I do find it quite problematic
that we are allowing this
narrative around crime
and violence in our
communities to just state
or at least to go mainstream
through the voices of some
Black institutional leaders,
both political, religious,
cultural, and otherwise.
You know, it's a
fascinating thing you know,
a lot of the narrative around,
you know, the rise in crime
and the need for kind
of punitive response.
In the 90s, we know had
lots of faith leaders
standing up in press
conferences with mayors
and elected officials, you know,
saying this is the way forward.
And yet we also know that
over the last couple years,
events like, what was
the name of this thing
that the police were doing?
It was called faith in the
blue or something like that.
These targeted outreaches
to Black religious leaders
to sit down with law enforcement
and craft public safety
plan when the average faith leader
is not even in relationships,
with some of the very
impacted individuals.
And I say, this doesn't favor
because I had lots of clergy
calling me across the country,
said, "Pastor Mike should
I get involved in this?"
And I said, "If your first conversation
"around violence is with a prosecutor,
"a politician, or a police officer,
""then you ought to
probably stay in the stands
"til you talk to Pookie
or Ray-Ray," right?
'Cause you don't have
enough information, right,
to be in that conversation
a way that actually will get the result
that you say you want,
which is peace in our communities.
And so right now,
as the Biden administration, right,
we have been pushing out
this $5 billion investment
that folks like in our fund,
peace coalition, other folks,
you know, gave the information
architecture to construct,
we're seeing right now across the country
that mayors have received ARP funds
over almost a billion dollars
I think of mayor commitments
to put ARP funds,
the American Rescue Plan dollars
into community vice interventions,
and less than 10% of those funds
have even moved into the community.
So it is not just even
about accessing resources
is about having the leadership in place
at the executive level,
at the communal level
and in the neighborhoods
that can show that their love
for our communities see them
not just as a problem to be solved,
but a solution to be unleashed.
And that work,
I think is really the next frontier
of the Black radical tradition,
not just from a scholastic point of view,
but what does it mean to
radically love Black folks
to be proximal to the
conditions of Black folks?
What does it mean for intellectual giants
in cities and universities to
be in proximity to organizers
on the ground and folks in neighborhoods
who are impacted by this
so our work can be braided together?
I think that is another
part of the conversation
of how we collapse these
false distinctions and roles
into something that could be
much more glorious and healing.
- Thank you, go ahead, Brandon.
- Yeah, I'm really
taking the endeavor part
of this seriously.
So I'm trying out ideas and I'm curious
to get a response because
I think, you know,
there's an amazing essay
by Frederick Douglass
that I love to teach called,
"Is it Right and Wise
to Kill a Kidnapper?"
And he's talking about
fugitive slave catchers.
And what I love about that essay
is that it captures a real problem
in Black political thought.
Is that you're always thinking
about what are rights, right?
What are duties, obligations,
what's legitimate?
What do you have to do
as a matter of morality?
And you're also trying to think
about things would be good, right?
So you might not be obligated to do them,
but they would be good if
you, in fact, did do them
and things that would be prudent.
So things that might be wise
to do and may be neither good,
nor just, and I go into
that digression just to say,
I agree that we probably
have no obligation to dispel
racist fantasies that proliferate
through the population
or punitive stigmas
against the ghetto poor.
But I think it is probably good to do so,
and probably wise to do so,
in so far as we think
that there is no plausible go it alone,
nationalist strategy.
And again, it goes back to
part of what I was getting at
in my remarks is that one of my concerns
with the community violence paradigm
is I think it does a lot
as an explanatory paradigm,
'cause it's coming out of
sociology, community studies,
social ecology,
but it brings a bunch
of normative resonances
from communitarianism,
from nationalism about
the ethics of community.
And the question is who's in
the community and who's not?
If we respond to Pastor Mike who says,
"Do we belong to America?"
The right arguments might
not entail entrenching
the problem deeper in an
isolated neighborhood space,
they might be about tethering these things
to a broader metropolitan strategy,
a broader national strategy.
That's one of my concerns here.
And I'm just curious as to
how people respond to it
because I think one of the
things that's really remarkable
to me about out the last 10, 15 years
is that all the hard
culture work, artistic work,
hip hop, film, music, the hard
political work and activism
I think has done a lot to
really change how people think
about the agential nature of crime
in ghetto community and the attribution
of moral responsibility for it.
And I think it's created
a broader constituency
than we've ever seen for these movements,
even though it's not
enough to win as of yet.
So, I'm suspicious of the
reflects of worry about it.
- You know, I appreciate that.
And I would say that
it good to do the work,
but it does not emerge
out of an obligation.
- Right, I agree.
- As an obligation suggests
criteria, you know,
characteristics of a relationship
that aren't actually their
relationship that we have, right.
And the challenge that we're confronting
and the language and the narrative,
I think is really important.
We are talking about evolution of a system
of racial domination in which
law enforcement has played
a central role, both
formal and informal, right.
Intra-legal, extra-legal
forms of law enforcement.
And that's what we are
contending with, right.
And a body politic that has supported that
in its different iterations over time.
And so we do the work
because the same reasons
that Du Bois did the work
and Ida B. Wells did the work, right.
And on and on,
and we do the work
and we have the
conversations within, right.
That aren't directed toward the White gays
and move us forward.
But I wouldn't say I
would stop short of saying
it's an obligation, it really
is about saving our own lives.
And I don't say that in a
hyperbolic sense at all.
I mean, I know you appreciate that,
but when you look at
the historical record,
that's what folks are trying to do.
And somehow we imagine that,
that we are in a different moment
and yet that is still
what we're trying to do.
Right.
- Yeah.
- Could I react to?
- Go ahead, go ahead Pastor Mike.
- Just real quick, I wanted
to react to another part
of what Brandon said,
because, you know, I do find
the language of community
violence as a kind of
descriptor of the way
in which violence, uniquely visits,
Black and Brown communities
within the kind of larger
context of the gun violence
conversation in this
country to be an output
of how many of us who have been
working at the intersection
of gun violence, victimization,
Black and Brown communities
largely found our
experiences being erased,
if not altogether left to
a law enforcement punitive
only conversation.
So as to when you join a gun violence
prevention conversation,
and the only conversation
about second amendment,
right? Right?
And then folks are like, well,
what about these other public
health related strategy?
What about talking about
criminal justice reform
within the "gun violence"
prevention movement,
or talking about issues of poverty
and other forms of violence?
We were told, well, that is
not gun violence prevention.
- [Philip] Yeah.
- Work.
Right, and so we had
to create new language.
And I just say all that,
it's say part of what I
think could be an endeavor
is how do we create new language together
that actually captures that,
which we say we are trying to accomplish.
And I do think this is
perhaps part of the project
of building and reimagining public safety
by centering those directly
impacted by these issues
versus us doing a reactionary move,
whether it's around narrative
policy and or solutions
to these arbitrary rises and spikes
in crime and violence
that are often politicized
in the moment but not necessarily
over a long period of time
done as a constructive
project around democracy,
because, you know,
how can one, you know,
really love the country
or the city they're in,
if they can't even imagine
they're going to live very long
within it, right?
It is almost a decoupling
of one spirit in humanity.
And so I do think the
community violence narrative
is both helpful, but also challenging.
And I hope we can endeavor to, again,
be very clear about what we want to say
and how we want to
imagine the world forward
when we're talking about these issues.
- I appreciate all that.
And Brandon I wanna add too,
and then pivot to a different question,
which is a synthesis of
a couple that I've gotten
in the chat here.
'Cause I think part of
what you're bringing up
is that regardless of what
a moral obligation might be,
particularly from a collective
and community perspective,
there is work that is likely necessary
in order to achieve certain names.
This group is not called
Black elected political work
in the context of community violence.
It is called right, Black activism
and so I'm wondering to the
degree to which, and Pat,
if I can sort of direct this to you,
the degree to which it is clear
what the role of activism should be
versus what the role of the
state should be in this,
particularly at a moment
when we're seeing the federal government
is putting more money into programs
like violence interruption, right?
And that federal and and state dollars
are going more to these
nonprofit community elements.
The nonprofit sphere has
traditionally been supposed
to be for places that the
state need not or cannot go,
and yet, as we think
about scaling responses
to community violence,
we see the state starting to get involved,
which leads to this sort of muddying
where there are folks who are
saying no defund the police
as the slogan needs to serve
these particular partisan
interests versus it has
nothing to do with y'all.
Please don't talk about it
'cause you didn't show up at the rally.
So you don't get a say.
So Pat, can you talk just a
little bit about this moment
that we've got where there is
funding flowing to nonprofits
from the state and whether
or not some of the work
that nonprofits have been doing,
particularly the work you've been studying
belongs with the state or does
it belong with the community?
- Yeah, big questions.
You know, I think of this
topic that we're talking about
was created by the state.
This was a result of interventions
over a long period of time.
And I think one of the points that I heard
Dr. Terry push us to maybe think about
is how do we talk about
this problem of violence
and expand it so that it
we're talking about it
in relational terms?
We're talking about it, not as a problem
that is concentrated in low
income communities of color,
but as a consequence of
a set of interventions
that have been carried out over decades
and longer, where, and
I saw Elizabeth Hinton
is in the room somewhere.
She should, everything that
I've learned about this,
I've learned from reading her
work and other historians,
but this is a product,
this is actively produced
when the federal government invested
in an interstate highway
system and subsidized mortgages
that allowed people who could afford a car
and firms were able to
lead central city unions,
central cities to avoid big city unions
that have become more and more powerful
when we give enormous capacity
to local municipal governments
to decide who can live
in that space.
So if you like, for instance,
if you wanna look at
St. Louis in Ferguson,
well first think back to
when the White population
of St. Louis was subsidized
to lead to the suburbs
and then formed new municipalities
and then zoned it all
for single family homes
so that their property
values rose really quickly,
and the property values in
St. Louis fell very quickly.
That's the basis for how
you get decades later
what happened to Michael Brown?
That's the basis for how St.
Louis became the most violent
city in the country.
Those active of interventions,
which now take the form
of land use regulations
and gated communities and
this spatial infrastructure
of inequality that the
state has built over time.
So when I'm listening to Dr. Terry,
in my mind, it reinforced this notion
that we have to understand this challenge
in relational terms,
we have to understand it as
a consequence of conscious,
intentional, interventions
carried out over decades
that have led to this form
of extreme inequality,
which then creates the
conditions for vials to emerge.
When people retreat from their homes,
when they've the core
institutions of the community
are not supported,
then you create the conditions
where violence can emerge.
So circling back to your question, Phil,
I think it is unfair.
I think it is unsustainable.
And I think it is in effective
to think of this project
of responding to these
interventions carried over
out over decades with another project
that doesn't feature the
state with another project
that doesn't assume that
we need public funding,
120 billion a year spent
on law enforcement.
You know, what if the
groups run by Pastor Mike
and Fund Peace had a 100
billion dollar budget per year,
per year, not 5 billion
at one point in time,
but a 100 billion per year.
What would communities
look like at that point?
And so, you know, I always go back
when I lived to in Manhattan for 11 years,
and I was in NYU housing
right in Washington Square.
And I was not once asked to
volunteer my time or my money
to go deal with the problem
of violence in my community.
And so if we're going to
mount a sustained project
to deal with this,
I don't think it can rely
on people volunteering.
I don't think it can rely on organizations
that are fighting for
every dollar they receive.
I think it has to be a
project that is funded
through the mechanism of the state.
- And I'll just add to that,
that as much as I appreciate
Pastor Mike and the work that he does
and the work that folks
I've written about are doing
as well there's a way
that that can presume
that the conditions don't change
so that the organizations
are going to be needed
to do the work that they're doing now.
So if we take a step back,
we're actually talking about a project
of reparations, right.
An investment, right.
An acknowledgement of the harm
and some financial redress
for all of what the state interventions
that Pat just laid up.
But we stopped short of that, right.
And there's a reason that
we stop short of that,
and our stopping short of that
is what allows the problem
to continue and us to
have these conversations
about which kinds of interventions
make the most sense, right.
And what we ought to do,
not acknowledging that we are
not all the same we, right.
And the community is not all
the same community, right.
The politics of the community are real.
And those are also
manufactured both internally,
but also by the state.
So I think part of what I've tried to do
over the last couple of years is to think
in a real, you know, honest
way about the situation
in which we find ourselves, right.
And if we think about what Pat laid out
around residential segregation
and the construction
of Whiteness and the battle
for Whiteness right now.
And what we saw in the insurrection
is the kind of crisis of Whiteness.
Like what is Whiteness
gonna mean in this country?
And that's consequential for Black people,
to the extent we're talking
about Black people, right.
Because of always include
some reference to Black people
and the condition of Black people,
whether they are there or
not, right in this nation.
So the question isn't
as much about, you know,
are we part of America, right?
It is, is America an America
that has the kinds of
institutions that can include us?
So what I've done there is to
take us like many degrees away
from what people, the narrative
of gun violence, right.
And building on what
other folks have said.
And, you know, I say
that not to stop put halt
to the conversation, but
just to kind of, you know,
to really get us closer to the problem
as we're dealing with it as
it as we're confronting it.
- Yeah, and Brandon, I see
you take yourself off mute.
You wanna get in on this?
- Yeah.
Because I think to this point,
you know, we're thinking in the aftermath
of some really momentous things,
and I really appreciate it
how you set us up, Phil.
It's not just the biggest protest
movement in world history.
It's also the largest influx of cash
into Black led political
organizations in history.
And I think one of the things
that many of us knew before
last month, but have all been
forced to deal with in public
last month is that that didn't go well.
Cash came in, there was an
infrastructure to deal with it.
It papered over a lot of
rhetoric papered over,
who was making decisions,
what constituencies they
were accountable to,
what philanthropic
dollars demanded in return
for their commitments.
That it's a whole set
of democratic deficits
that emerge when this
happens in an ad hoc fashion,
as a dance between philanthropists,
activist and a media
climate that gravitates
towards spectacular acts
of violence.
So I just raised that to say
that one of the biggest
problems for Black activism,
one, which we have basically
no conceptual resources
to deal with, 'cause it
hasn't been a problem before.
It's like how to manage
enormous amounts of money
in a way that is
democratically defensible.
Or if not, it's not going to
appeal to norms of democracy,
give us reasons why we should not demand
those democratic norms
be shown fidelity to.
The alternative, what I think
Professor Sharkey's laying out
is really a remaking of the state.
And again, that's just not a project
that Black political thought has tended
to have a lot of
resources to try to think,
but it's our opportunity to do so,
to establish a new progressivism
that really thinks about what
might new and novel state
institutions look like
as we try to onboard the
work of community repair
into a state apparatus
that might be deserving
of the ascent and respect and commitment
of the people who are right
now the truly disadvantaged.
- Yeah Brandon, I just wanna
pick up on one thread of that.
I'm so glad that you were
talking about the amount of money
that philanthropy puts in
to Black Lego organizations,
Black led political power,
but it has been to the
criminal legal space
and to the public safety
space in particular
over the last two years.
I wanna just sort of add
friendly amendments on two parts.
One while the public rhetoric
was about Black led organizations
and the public scrutiny
has absolutely been
Black led organizations.
The majority of the money
that went into the public safety space
was not to Black led organizations, right?
And this sort of new
problem of sort of windfall
of capital within the
space is absolutely new
to Black political projects,
but not new to nonprofit
spaces quite nonprofits, right?
So there are examples of this
happening within the climate
justice space, within women's
reproductive health space,
with sexual orientation spaces
where exactly the same kinds
of sort of cardboard edifices
on the fronts of nonprofits fall down
with the windfall of cash, right?
And then the ecosystem
sort of reconstructs itself
amidst that this is a predictable cycle
when we rely on nongovernmental.
So it's philanthropic,
non-governmental resources
to get stuff done.
And yet I do believe that the narrative
that's gonna emerge from this
is gonna be quite distinct
because of the racialization
of this work, right?
Oh boy, do I wish that we had
seven hours to do just this.
I wanna be responsive to all the messages
that are coming in.
It looks like 100% of
them are direct messages.
Right now so I wanna make a pivot
'cause I've had two folks ask now
about given that we're
talking about attention
between whether or not we want
community to genuinely lead
outside of government where
we wanna be remaking the state
as Brandon, you framed,
this question as to what
is the role of activism
if it is genuinely community
or to be community led
in responding to community trauma per se,
as opposed to medical
community and the state,
considering the historic
neglect of community trauma
particularly in Black communities,
and Pastor Mark I'm gonna go ahead
and give that to you first.
- Well, I think the role is the both end
but the emphasis to me, you know,
continues to have to be around, you know,
both leadership and agencies.
You know, I think many
of us who are in that
"activism organizing space,"
appreciate that every system we engage
is one built inherently with
Anti-Blackness embedded in it.
Like none of us are
like walking around here
really thinking that whether
it's a Black, Brown, Latino,
Latin, that and that, LGBTQ
person leading such institution
anti-Blackness is all through that.
And yet we know that we must
figure out ways to redeem
what's redeemable and transform
what must be jettison.
And so for us, it's
about imagination, right?
It's about how can we
create new structures
within the redeemable
parts of these systems
that have community, power, leadership,
and accountability at the center of it,
not in some kind of ceremonial way,
but in a real distinct way,
we can fire, we can hire,
we can audit, we can make
corrective kind of decision making
along the way to ensure
that community activism,
interest, priorities remain
at the heart of these said
both interventions or kind
of programmatic responses
to both the immediacy of the problem
and certainly the kind
of long term trajectory
of the solution.
One thing we ask often
and we wrestle with this
in our organizing is I love
to put this out for folks
here is, you know, what is
the trajectory, the timeline,
the kind of Hansel and Gretel crumbs,
Hansel and Gretel crumbs that you put
so people can follow along in the journey
towards abolitionist reality
or a reality where police budgets
are less than the majority
or significant part of a general fund
and we are as Brother Sharkey
you mentioned literally
that dollar for dollar investing
in both community healing,
community repair, repressions, like,
you know, what's the timeline to that?
How do we get there?
How do we help people appreciate that
organizing along the way,
activism along the way is
the trajectory of that?
And it's very hard when the
material conditions of people
every day are experiencing
the concreteness
of the loss of lives,
the bruising of bodies, the
intimate partner violence,
the lethal conflicts that play out,
literally outside people's homes.
Like folks can't think
20 years in the future,
if they can't imagine how
to get their kid to school today, right.
And so our task is to
help balance the tension
between the hearing now and
the Black future, right.
I hear folks talk about Black history.
You know, when you talk
about Black future,
I say, no, we talking about all of it,
but not one sector of our work
can hold all of it, right?
And so this is where I think
it has to be a both end
in my mind, both around
imagining, around implementing,
around evaluating, around sustaining.
And some of that will be
done in some of these systems
that have both redemptive and
unredemptive components of it.
And some will have to be done
apart from those systems.
The question is, can our
brilliance, our humility,
our collaboration, our
intentionality help us
be able to change both the near term
and the far term conditions?
And I think that is a big part of work,
but I am always captured by this question,
Dr. King, "How Long?" Right.
And I think that is a question
for so many in the community,
how long must we live in these conditions
without reprieve and reparations,
a lot of us talk about reparations,
but we don't even have all,
every Black person in this country
feel like who should get reparation?
What does reparation look like?
You know, if you from Jamaica,
some folk don't think you
should get reparation.
I'm like, "My God, when did
that start happening?" Right.
So we got a lot of work to
do to just bring us together.
But I do find this to be a both end,
at least in how I'm hearing the question.
- Yeah, I think that's true
of this conversation too.
Black folks don't all agree, right.
If people don't all agree on
the starting point, right.
And so what I see that
question as a starting point
in the same way that perhaps
talking about the body
of research,
I think the body of
research on reparations
is building up as well.
I think Sandy William
Darity work on reparations
and the distinct kind of
the justifications for it
and how it might play out
is one example of that.
I just wanna go back to one point
and Brandon, you might, you
know, because of your expertise,
you can help me think
about this, but the idea,
I don't think that you're
saying that Black people
haven't been engaged with
the making of the state,
or maybe distinguishing
between Black people
and Blackness, right.
Because we know the state as it exists,
is in response in part to Blackness
and the understanding of that, right.
And so the question for me
is how is it that the demands
that are being made are incorporated
into not just a state, but
that a state that is, you know,
when you think about
abolitionist imagining
can actually create the
kinds of institutions
that are necessary for
the population of people
we have within these borders now,
while also accounting, right
for the sovereign territory
and the unseated territory
and all that.
So that's a big question,
but thinking, you know,
acknowledging the fact that
even in this conversation,
there is a possibility
to remake the state,
but it can't be on the
conditions of the state.
And that's why I keep coming
back to this point that,
that we have to confront directly
the violence of the state.
You can't kind of, you
know, move around it.
And what does that mean
in a very material sense
to take Pastor Mike's point?
That means that when a young
man tells me that he grew up
with the hands of police
officers down his pants,
as a consequence of this war on drugs,
that was a war on young people,
my politics, my practice has
to get in the way of that.
Has to interrupt that, has to disrupt that
because whatever you
think about crime rates
and bringing them down
that cannot be a way
in which we do it, right.
And so, and we know like just the history
of Black feminist thought
shows us the many, many ways
that Black women have
cared for one another,
cared for the community, right.
And so that we know those
very material practices
in a tradition of that exists.
And so, you know, I think
it is this both end,
but we cannot get out
of this where we are,
we cannot do this
remaking, this reimagining,
this transformation without
a direct confrontation.
Confrontation which will feel
antagonistic to some folks
with state violence.
- Yeah, I don't disagree with that.
I mean, I should be more
precise where I think,
you know, look, we have an
enormously rich tradition.
I've devoted my life to studying
Black political thought.
I think like any genre
of political thought,
there are things that traditions fixate on
because they have to.
So, you see in other traditions,
like if you take kinda
19th and 20th century
German political thought,
you just see a lot of focus on
how to develop a bureaucracy,
'cause they're engaged in
the process of doing that.
Not a lot of our thinkers
were allowed to participate
in the act of construction
of the bureaucracies
that we live under,
we have a much richer tradition
of how to think about
the ethics of protests
and the ethics of resistance.
So that's all I was just trying to say
is that for our generation of thinkers,
one of the difficult moves
is going to be, you know,
coming down on this question
of do we need to develop
more more sustained forms of state craft
and how can we rethink the state?
What is our conception of the state?
And what might state
institutions look like?
I was using the progressive
era as an analogy
because it's one of the
moments in American history
where left liberals spend
a lot of time thinking
about how the state might
operate very differently
than it did prior, right.
Getting rid of patronage appointments,
trying to think about the
spoil system, things like that.
So just one quick example, you know,
do we have a unitary
conception of the state
that we're operating with, right?
Or is the state a jumble
of competing interest
in the institutions,
which we might see some element
of and use them as a counter
power to parts of the state
that we're antagonistic toward.
That's just an open
political theory question
that I don't think we have a
lot of debate about right now
in the space of public safety.
So I wanted to say that.
And then the second thing,
just more directly to Pastor Mike's point,
which I think is really important.
So how do we convince people?
What are the breadcrumbs, you know,
use the analogy to breadcrumbs.
It's like a lot of my work
right now is about narratives,
narratives of history.
And one of my deep
concerns is the popularity
of what I call ironic narratives,
but other people might
call pessimist narratives
or Afro-pessimist narratives
that really diminish the
significance of partial victories
and treat them as elusory,
meaningless, non-events,
I think that's really demoralizing
to a social movement struggle
to the kind of practice
that Du Bois called the "long siege,"
which I think is would any struggle
against the history of White
supremacy in this country,
and the current practice of
White supremacy in this country
is gonna look like.
And I think we have to be really careful
that although such narratives
can feel cathartic,
'cause they allow us to
denounce all existence
in one sweep that they
can be really demoralizing
on the ground.
So that's one thing I
think we have to avoid
or narratives that
diminish partial victories.
We need to find ways of
lifting up partial victories
while still acknowledging
how partial they are.
And then the other thing I was gonna say
is that from African-American history,
I always I'm enamored with, you know,
I'm teaching class on Malcolm X now,
I always teach classes
on a Black Power movement
and think a lot about the Panthers.
And I think for everyone
who struggles with the
history of Black radicalism,
one of the things that's really appealing
about those two movements,
the movement around Malcolm X
and the movement around the Panthers
is that they were able to get people
who are involved in the perpetration
of public space violence to participate
actively in political struggle.
And to me that just is
still the holy grail.
That's still proof of concept
that can you show people
in Black communities,
poor of Black communities
that you can reach folks
who everyone else thinks nobody can reach?
And that need to be thrown away,
need to be locked away incapacitated.
When you can reach those people
and show their political moral agency,
their genius, their creativity,
I think there's just
something still spectacular
and compelling and persuasive
about that project,
but it is extraordinarily difficult.
- I really I'm, at this point,
I went from frustrated to being angry
that this conversation can't go longer.
I wanna respect folks time.
We're coming up on about 14 minutes left
and I swore to all the panelists,
they were having a chance
to do closing remarks.
So we're gonna go through
those closing remarks.
Part of me wants to know about what is,
and isn't new?
Brandon you talked about partial victories
and I thought I was in
Pastor Mike's church
when I was saying, amen to it,
the tensions between what we can get today
versus what we must demand for tomorrow,
which are clearly be part
of this long struggle,
but feel like they're having
a different conversation
right now.
All of that, but I'll
leave with this prompt
and then ask folks to take
just two to three minutes
to wrap up, respond to
the prompt or don't.
But the prompt coming in, again,
as a synthesis from a couple
of the direct messages,
we've talked, this is a
conversation framed around
what organizers and activists
can do in this moment.
And if you could name the
one thing, the one thing,
the one constraint on activism right now,
the one constraint that if we removed it
would be the biggest lever
on change that we could do.
The one constraint that could be removed.
Go ahead and name that,
and then go ahead and wrap up.
We're gonna go in the same
order, Dr. Nikki Jones,
if you wanna go ahead and start us off.
- Oh, (Nikki chuckles) there
is no one thing, right?
We are operating in a structural context
that positions activists and
organizers and there's overlap
and there's distinctions in certain ways,
has them in a place.
And that that is built
in to the work, right?
That has been the long struggle.
I'm not a pessimist
and yet I don't see that
changing in the near future.
What I know is happening
is that the people
who were instigating
and motivating the work
that led to the uprisings of summer 2020
have not led up and they're
continuing to do that work.
And what becomes transformative
in any moment of rupture
is the set of ideas that
percolate to the surface.
And that's why this
rupture in summer 2020,
between reform and
abolition was so significant
and remains so consequential.
So even defund as a slogan,
didn't emerge in that moment,
as sure as folks here appreciate,
it emerged in Oakland years before, right?
In response to a very material problem.
And then that leads to the cert...
And the reaction to that
is what leads to change.
We don't wanna defund the police,
but maybe we'll think
about relocating resources.
Maybe we'll think about a
department of public safety
in Minneapolis,
which got 43% of the
vote which is not nothing
and probably before this moment,
wouldn't have gotten
12% of the vote, right?
And so I just wanna bring our attention
to the fact that this work is happening.
This change is happening,
and the people who are
closest to the problem
are the ones who are figuring it out.
The question for the we that
exists here in some respect.
And I'll think I'll say
something specifically
about the we in the academy
is to acknowledge our role
in producing the conditions
that we have talked about
over the course of our
time together today,
and to rethink how we
reallocate our resources, right?
So that we are funneling
the power of the university
to those who need it most.
So to me, I see that as the
kind of, you know, the practice,
the liberatory practice,
the fusion practice that
we need to be invested
in this moment and that is
actually most sensitive, right.
And has the kind of most accurate
reading of the conditions
in which we find ourselves.
I'll stop there.
- Thanks, thank you.
Yeah, Dr. Pat Sharkey.
- So I've learned when I
should sit out a question
and listen and I think this is a question
that where it's better for me to listen
than anything else,
but what I will say is
that as following up
on Nikki's powerful point
about what role academics play.
One of the things that I've learned
about particularly my role,
what a White academic can play,
who doesn't do the work on the ground,
who doesn't do the
ethnography that Nikki does,
who does quantitative
work to try to understand
these challenges we're talking about?
I've found that my job
is to relentlessly focus
on explanation, relentlessly
move past the observation
of inequality, the
description of inequality
and toward explanation.
And that's why I go to
Elizabeth Hinton's work
and why it's so powerful
because it gives academics
the tools to say, okay,
here's a challenge.
Now let's understand where this arose
and what were the intentional policies
and what were the
impacts of those policies
and those social movements
that led to this form of
inequality that we're now seeing?
And so I'll stop there and just say,
I see my job as an academic
to just relentlessly focus
on explanation and never stop
until I have made the empirical point
about what led to this point.
- Thank you, Pat.
Dr. Brandon Terry final thoughts.
- Yeah, well, this is
a really hard question.
And I think from me the biggest obstacle,
and I think the biggest
thing that's changed
since the last major
wave of Black radicalism
in the late 1960s and early 1970s
is the carceral state itself.
I mean, we've just taken a lot
of brilliant, hard working,
interesting people out of
circulation and public space.
And unlike the era of the
great prison movements
of the late 1960s and early 1970s
is also really, really
difficult to organize in prisons
in ways, I mean, it was
always difficult to organize
in prisons, but it's
become in some respects,
even more difficult.
People can't even get their
hands on books to read
without severe censorship and
surveillance and repression.
And these things have
only gotten more intense
in the wake of the pandemic
where there's been really harsh lockdowns
and lots of facilities.
And so one of the problems that creates
is that it really
intensifies the disconnect
that Pastor Mike was speaking about,
of people trying to connect
the lived experience
of people most susceptible to,
and most likely to perpetrate
what we're calling community violence
and the politics that emerge from it.
And we haven't really
been able to develop,
there's some great experiments in this,
but there hasn't been a strategy
that quite seems scalable as of yet
about how to overcome that
the repressive function
of the carceral state on
radical politics in this moment.
So that would be the biggest thing.
And I think as academics, you know,
one of the things we can
contribute to that project
is really doing the hard
work of normative analysis
to try to, you know, the
old work of critical theory,
clarifying the struggles of the age.
Like let's really clarify
what people are arguing,
why they're saying things are unjust?
What kinds of norms they're appealing to?
What are the differences
between duties, goods,
and just prudential considerations?
Why those might matter?
Because they help open up
the space of persuasion
for allies we're asking to risk a lot
in the struggles against authoritarianism,
whether it takes the form of the prison
or whether it takes the form
of the anti-democratic movements
we're seeing insurgent today.
- Thank you, Brandon.
And last, but certainly
not least Pastor Mike.
- You know, this question
about what is one thing
I'm like Dr. Jones,
you know, when I say God, I
mean, Father, Son, Holy Spirit,
we gotta start at least with
three things a good preacher,
you know, in me, but I do
worry about isolationism,
you know, like that we can become isolated
in our silos by just the rigor of the work
that we are all called to do uniquely.
And that isolationism creates
a level of incompatibility
over time where we just can't even,
we can say the same word,
but not mean the same thing.
And so, you know, I wonder
like, can we walk together?
How can we walk together?
You know, I'm finding this
to be the biggest challenge
in our movement space,
post the Ferguson uprising, et cetera,
"Black Lives Matter,"
however you wanna describe it.
A lot of us aren't
walking together anymore
and that's just within
one part of the movement.
Like how can we walk together as you know,
across disciplines, across
the academy, across religious,
you know, movements,
across elected officials,
it's like how can we walk together?
And it is frightening for me
to think about these
authoritarian impulses
sweeping the country, and we
who are in its cross hairs,
can't figure out how to walk together,
not in some kumbaya our way,
but just in a relational manner
where we can have a conversation over time
and do the dreaming that we
all say we want to do, right.
It's not to me about intentions,
it's just about how can we
just functionally walk together
this capitalist economy that makes us,
I have to write papers, preach message,
like, you know, I gotta get a new thing
to say every week, right?
The same message every
week differently, right?
A capitalistic endeavor
somebody's doing there, right.
Or I figure out a new organizing plan
every week, every month.
And that work in and of itself,
it I think often keeps our relationships
from being little deep and life giving.
So that's what I would say.
And I do believe we have
massive opportunities,
but it is still early.
These same opportunities
could become Trojan horses
to continue to fund the
state, the incarcerated state,
the police state,
all these things that
we know are problematic.
And so I do hope that as we continue
to lean into this moment,
we can maximize these opportunities
to both recreate, but also
dismantle those things
that cause us harm.
Thanks for having me though,
Dr. Phil and everybody.
- See, I thought we were so close.
We were so close to getting
outta one session together
with no Dr. Phil references
and there at the very end,
(Philip laughs) my brother,
this has been such a
nourishing conversation.
Thanks the four of y'all.
Before I let folks go,
I wanna make sure that we
get a special shout out
to Vanessa Epps who helped
get all the logistics
of this together.
Make sure that our panelists were here.
You know she made all of us
look significantly better
than we would have otherwise.
So thank you so much, Vanessa.
Thank you all for coming.
I cannot wait for the next and
the next of these endeavors,
but please join me.
Raise your hands,
take yourselves off mute
and thanking our panelists
for sharing their wisdom and
their brilliance with us today.
Thank y'all so, so, so much.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much.